la campaña no se detuvo el día de
navidad antes de las elecciones en la
república centroafricana programadas
para hoy
la oposición había pedido que les
cancelarán debido a los recientes
enfrentamientos y la inestabilidad
[Música]
tenemos un proceso organizativo
completamente defectuoso
cuando hay preocupaciones por la
inseguridad y el hecho de que en todas
las ciudades haya grupos armados hindú
y el grupo de mickey of tax grupos y sus
el creo que es más prudente considerar
posponer las elecciones
y el sexo pero un tribunal
constitucional rechazó cualquier retraso
en los comicios del sábado mientras el
país se enfrenta a la crisis más grave
en años los grupos rebeldes lanzaron una
ofensiva hace una semana amenazando con
marchar sobre la capital banguí el
gobierno lo calificó de intento de golpe
coordinado por el ex presidente françois
bozizé pero las fuerzas rebeldes
conocidas como la coalición de patriotas
por el cambio dicen que es la
administración en ejercicio la que está
tratando de manipular la votación
se enviaron tropas de rusia así como de
ruanda para reforzar al gobierno
mondongo centroafricanos estad atentos
unamos nuestras manos a nuestros
soldados unamos nuestras manos a la
minustah unamos nuestras manos a otros
países la federación de rusia ruanda y
todos los que ayuden a fortalecer
nuestra seguridad van a la república
centroafricana es uno de los países más
pobres del continente y se ha visto
afectado por la inseguridad desde que
bosch y se fue derrocado en 2013